Rewrite the following
expression as the product
of positive exponents, and
then evaluate the expression
when x is equal to 2.
So they gave us x to
the negative 3 times
5 to the negative
2 times x squared.
So the main thing
to realize here
is if I have something
to a negative exponent,
this is the exact
same thing as 1
over that same base to
the positive version
of the exponent.
So x to the negative a is
equal to 1 over x to the a.
So using this knowledge, let's
just apply it right over here.
So x to the negative 3
power, we can rewrite as 1
over x to the third power.
And then 5 to the
negative 2, we can
rewrite as 1 over 5 squared.
And then finally, we
have times x squared.
And so we can multiply this out.
In the numerator, we
have 1 times 1 times
x squared, which is
just equal to x squared.
In the denominator, we have x
to the third times 5 squared.
5 squared is 25.
And here, you could say
implicitly there is a 1.
This is the same thing
as x squared over 1.
So in the denominator, we
have 25 times x to the third.
So this is going to be
25 times x to the third.
And then we can
simplify this even more
because both the numerator
and the denominator
is divisible by x squared.
x squared divided
by x squared is 1.
x to the third
divided by x squared
is just going to be equal to x.
And you could use other
exponent properties.
You could say x squared
over x to the third
is the same thing as x to
the 2 minus 3 power, which
is x to the negative 1 power.
But x to the negative
1 power, we know
is the same thing as 1/x.
Any way you do it, as long as
you do it in a reasonable way,
you should get the same result.
So when we simplify
it, we get 1/25x.
Now, they want us to evaluate
when x is equal to 2.
So if x is equal to 2,
we get 1 over 25 times 2,
which is equal to 1/50.
And we are done.
We rewrote the expression as a
product of positive exponents.
That's right over here.
We made all the
exponents positive.
And then we evaluated,
and we got 1/50.